This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. There's an old story by H.G. Wells, the science fiction writer, called The Country of the Blind. In it, he imagines the civilization of blind men and women who live in a hidden mountain valley without any knowledge of the sighted world. One day, an explorer stumbles across it. He's on an expedition in the Andes and gets separated from his team. And in a landslide falls into this forgotten valley
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。科幻作家 H.G.威尔斯有一篇名为《盲人国》的老故事。在故事中，他想象了一个盲人男女的文明，他们生活在一个隐藏的山谷里，对看得见的世界一无所知。一天，一个探险家无意中走进了这里。他在安第斯山脉探险时与队伍走散了，在一场山体滑坡中跌入了这片被遗忘的山谷，
that has existed sort of out of contact with the rest of human civilization for many, many, many generations. That's a reporter and author, Andrew Leeland. And it's the proverbial country of the blind. This explorer, his name is Nunez, enters it with a kind of very colonial attitude like, oh, well, you know, he keeps on repeating to himself in the land of the blind, the one-eyed man is king, and he sort of thinks he'll just sort of single-handedly dominate them,
这里与人类文明的其他部分几乎完全隔绝了许多、许多、许多代人。说话的是记者兼作家安德リュー·利兰（Andrew Leland）。这就是那句西方谚语中的盲人国。这位名叫努涅斯的探险家带着一种非常殖民主义的态度走了进去，心想，哦，好吧，你知道的，他一直在心里对自己重复，在盲人的国度里，独眼龙就是国王，他觉得自己能够轻而易举地独自统治他们，
and then he comes to discover that the world is really built for blindness and not for sightedness, and actually they're the ones with all the power. And it's a lot about this question of escape versus assimilation, which in a lot of ways reflected my own experience of becoming blind and gradual vision loss. Andrew compares himself to Nunes, an accidental and sometimes wary visitor to the strange and often beautiful country of the blind. Andrew was diagnosed with a degenerative eye disease during his freshman year in college. Over the past couple of decades, he's slowly been going blind, but he still has some side.
然后他发现这个世界其实是为了盲人而不是为了视力健全的人建造的，实际上他们才是一切权力的掌控者。这个故事很大程度上探讨了逃避与同化的问题，这在很多方面反映了我自己失明和视力逐渐丧失的经历。安德鲁把自己比作努涅斯，一个偶尔心怀戒备的访客，意外闯入了这片陌生而又美丽的盲人国度。安德鲁在大一的时候被诊断出患有一种退化性眼部疾病。在过去的几十年里，他的视力在慢慢变差，但他仍然保留了一些视力。
So he exists between worlds, based with a choice. Is this sort of dichotomy between, do I embrace this? Is do I assimilate? Do I become a citizen of this country, or do I rage against it and search for a cure and cling to the person who I was before losing vision. Andrew Leland has a book out today named after H.G. Wells's story. We're going to talk to him a little bit about the book later on the show, but first we wanted to re-air a story that Andrew did for us a few years ago about the long and fascinating history of blind reading technologies.
所以他游走于不同的世界之间，面临着一种选择。这种二分法在于，我是该接受这一切？还是该同化？我是该成为这个国家的一分子，还是该对此感到愤怒、寻找治疗方法，并紧紧抓住失去视力之前的那个自己不放？安德鲁·利兰今天出版了一本以 H.G.威尔斯的故事命名的新书。稍后我们在节目中会和他聊聊这本书，但首先，我们想重播几年前安德鲁为我们制作的一档节目，讲述盲人阅读技术漫长而迷人的历史。
Enjoy. [♪ Music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in in the habit while everyone else played kickball. In middle school, he learned the trade names of the book imprints that published the drug y contemporary fiction that he was starting to get into. And in 2003, he dropped out of college and moved to San Francisco to work for his favorite publisher, McSweeney's. It was my dream job, and working there exacerbated my already intense fetish for print. That's Andrew. I got to live out my fantasy of being an ink stained wretch, even if that meant logging 12-hour days at an inkless computer.
请欣赏。[♪ 背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，当其他人都在玩踢球游戏时，他养成了这种习惯。在初中时，他记住了那些出版他开始接触的当代先锋小说的图书品牌的名称。2003年，他从大学辍学，搬到旧金山，为他最喜欢的出版商麦克斯威尼（McSweeney's）工作。这是我梦寐以求的工作，在那里工作加剧了我对印刷品本已狂热的迷恋。说话的是安德鲁。我实现了自己成为一个浑身沾满墨水的穷酸文人的幻想，尽管这意味着要在没有墨水的电脑前工作12个小时。
I edited essays and interviews, laid out articles, and took a weird amount of pleasure in typographical minutia, like italicizing commas and rewriting headlines so they fit the frame just so. At McSweeney's, books and magazines were never just containers for words. They were works of art unto themselves. And I was trained to take as much care with the look and feel of the print as I did with the expression of the ideas in the text. But as much as Andrew loved print, he still loves it, in fact. He also has a condition that will eventually change his relationship to it pretty radically.
我编辑散文和采访，排版文章，并且对排版细节有着异乎寻常的喜爱，比如把逗号斜体化，重写标题以便它们刚好契合版面。在麦克斯威尼，书籍和杂志从来不仅仅是文字的容器。它们本身就是艺术品。我接受过训练，对待印刷品的外观和质感要像对待文本中思想的表达一样细心。但尽管安德鲁如此热爱印刷品，事实上他现在依然热爱。他同时也患有一种最终会彻底改变他与印刷品关系的疾病。
I'm going blind, really, really slowly. will eventually change his relationship to it pretty radically. I'm going blind, really, really slowly. Right now, it's like I've got a foot in both worlds, blind and sighted. I have it a generative retinal disease that's given me severe tunnel vision, so basically no peripheral vision. It's like I'm peering at the world through a toilet paper tube, one that gets a little narrower every few months. Ten. Alright, I'm going to try to read this and then see if I got it right.
我正在失明，非常、非常缓慢地。最终会彻底改变他与印刷品关系的疾病。我正在失明，非常、非常缓慢地。现在，这就好像我一只脚踩在两个世界里，盲人的世界和有视力的世界。我患有一种遗传性视网膜疾病，导致我患有严重的管状视野，基本上没有周边视野。这就像我透过一个卫生纸筒窥视世界，这个纸筒每隔几个月就会变窄一点。十。好吧，我要试着读一下这个，然后看看我读得对不对。
Can we... My retinal specialist told me that I probably don't need to worry about losing the ability to read for another five years or so. But I've already started using a special digital program to learn Braille, which is not easy. Be cocky. What? I want to get a jump start before I actually need it. Recalc... Recacly...
我们能……我的视网膜专家告诉我，我大概在五年左右的时间内都不需要担心失去阅读能力。但我已经开始使用一个特殊的数字程序来学习盲文，这可不容易。自大点。什么？我想在真正需要它之前抢先一步。重新计算……重新……
What? A recycle. Can we recycle a metal can? I know I'll still be able to experience books for the rest of my life. I'm lucky to be going blind in the digital age and the golden age of audio. There's an abundance of well-produced audio books and technology that can read aloud almost anything that appears on a screen. Puzzles? My knees can ride a unicycle or do puzzles? My knees can ride a unicycle or do puzzles.
什么？回收。我们可以回收金属罐吗？我知道在我的余生中，我仍然能够体验书籍。我很幸运能在数字时代和音频的黄金时代失明。这里有大量制作精良的有声书，还有能够大声朗读屏幕上几乎任何内容的科技。拼图？我的膝盖能骑独轮车还是做拼图？我的膝盖能骑独轮车还是做拼图。
What the f*** did that mean? My knees can do no such thing. But despite all that, there's still some mellow tragedy in the idea that in a few years, I'll probably no longer be able to read print. After a life spent loving books, there's now a real urgency for me in the question of how blind people experience literature. I find myself deeply curious about what graphic design might mean to someone who can't see, and so I started looking into the history of reading technologies for the blind.
这特么是什么意思？我的膝盖才做不出这种事。但尽管如此，几年后我可能将无法再阅读印刷品这一想法中，仍然带有一种温和的悲剧色彩。在度过了一生对书籍的热爱之后，对于盲人是如何体验文学这个问题的紧迫感对我来说变得真实起来。我发现自己对平面设计对于一个看不见的人来说意味着什么充满了强烈的好奇心，所以我开始研究盲人阅读技术的发展史。
Traditionally, books are visual objects. And for centuries now, blind and sighted designers have been arguing over the most effective way to translate the visual ink print book into an accessible form for people without sight. For as long as blind people have been reading, there's been this tension between systems that try to stay close to the original form of a book and systems that dramatically depart from our ideas of what a book can be. Sighted designers have made incredible breakthroughs to create non-visual forms of reading for blind people. But, as one blind critic pointed out, sighted designers have a bad habit of,
传统上，书籍是视觉对象。几个世纪以来，盲人和视力健全的设计师一直在争论，如何将视觉上的油墨印刷书籍转化为视障人士可以使用的形式，才是最高效的途径。只要盲人还在阅读，这种张力就一直存在：一方面是试图贴近书籍原始形态的系统，另一方面是极大地偏离我们对书籍认知形态的系统。视力健全的设计师取得了令人难以置信的突破，为盲人创造了非视觉形式的阅读。但是，正如一位盲人评论家所指出的那样，视力健全的设计师有一个坏习惯，
quote, talking to the fingers in the language of the eyes. So the history of blind reading is really the history of finding a new language for the fingers and for the ears, one that captures the essential elements of the ink print book, but in a new language that's unbound from the visual. And that history centers around two main shapes, lines and dots. Our story starts in 18th century Europe before Braille was invented, before blind people were even taught to read at all. First off, no one thinks that it's possible for bonkids to learn.
引述，“用眼睛的语言与手指对话”。因此，盲人阅读的历史实际上就是为手指和耳朵寻找一种新语言的历史，这种新语言能够捕捉到油墨印刷书籍的精髓，但又是一种脱离了视觉的新语言。这段历史主要围绕着两种形状：线条和圆点。我们的故事始于18世纪的欧洲，在盲文发明之前，甚至在盲人被教导阅读之前。首先，没有人认为金基斯（bonkids）有可能学会阅读。
That's Mike Hudson, the museum director at the American printing house for the blind in Louisville, Kentucky. And if they could, no one knows how to do it. Without access to education, blind people were overwhelmingly poor, and their employment prospects were dim. If their families had enough money and time to support them, they usually lived at home,
说话的是迈克·哈德森（Mike Hudson），他是位于肯塔基州路易斯维尔的美国盲人印刷厂的博物馆馆长。即使他们能学会，也没有人知道该怎么做。由于无法获得教育，盲人绝大多数都很穷，他们的就业前景十分黯淡。如果他们的家庭有足够的金钱和时间来支持他们，他们通常就住在家里，
like adult children sitting idly around the house. Many others were forced to beg on the street. There were a handful of institutions in Europe to support the poorest cases, but they pitted the blind and hid them away from public view. But then this guy named Valentin Awee comes along. Awee was born into a family of weavers in France, and he was a skilled linguist.
就像成年子女一样无所事事地坐在家里。许多其他人被迫在街头乞讨。欧洲有少数机构来资助那些最贫困的案例，但他们把盲人关起来，让他们远离公众的视线。但随后一个名叫瓦朗坦·阿维（Valentin Avey）的人出现了。阿维出生于法国的一个织工家庭，他是一位精通语言的学者。
He was first inspired to help the blind in 1771. We saw a group of blind people being mocked during a street festival in Paris. They had been given dunce caps and giant fake glasses, and they were made to play musical instruments and pretend to read books. So, how we founded the first known school for the blind. It was called the Royal Institute in Paris. But even as he's getting the school going, how we kept a side gig. And a wheeze side gig is as a translator for the King of France. And so every now and then you'll get these fancy embossed invitations to a various events. And one day, one of Awee's students, a kid named Francois La Sour, touched one of them. And Francois La Sour notices that he can feel something
他在1771年首次萌生了帮助盲人的想法。当时他在巴黎的一个街头节日上看到一群盲人被嘲笑。他们被戴上了傻瓜帽和巨大的假眼镜，被迫演奏乐器并假装阅读书籍。于是，阿维创立了已知的第一所盲人学校。它被称为巴黎皇家研究所。但即便在学校建立的过程中，阿维还兼职做别的工作。阿维的兼职是法国国王的翻译。所以每隔一段时间，你就会收到这些精美的浮雕邀请函，邀请你参加各种活动。一天，阿维的一个学生，一个叫弗朗索瓦·拉索尔（Francois La Sour）的孩子，触摸了其中一张邀请函。弗朗索瓦·拉索尔注意到他能感觉到某些东西，
on these, on these imitations. And that gives us the idea, the idea to develop this idea of embossed printing in raised letters. So in 1786, how he makes the first machine embossed book for the blind. A treatise on blind education. It's written in print, the kind that cited readers would recognise,
在这上面，在这些仿制品上。这给了我们灵感，萌生了开发这种凸字印刷技术的想法。所以在1786年，阿维制作了第一台为盲人设计的机器浮雕书。这是一篇关于盲人教育的论文。它是用印刷体写的，也就是视力健全的读者能够认出的那种字体，
but the text is all raised so that blind students can feel the shape of the letters. And it's a radical move, not just the first book for blind readers in history, but basically the beginning of the idea that blind people can be educated. But there are a few problems. Well, first off, no one can afford to buy these books, okay? That's because the books are massive and prohibitively expensive, but they're also just really hard to read. They're filled with ornate 18th-century letter forms with their curly cues and flourishes which are confusing to the fingertips. It's not until many years later, near the end of Awee's life in 1821,
但所有的文本都是凸起的，这样盲人学生就能摸出字母的形状。这是一个激进的举措，不仅是历史上第一本专为盲人读者准备的书，而且基本上开启了“盲人也可以接受教育”这一理念的先河。但这里面有一些问题。首先，没有人买得起这些书，好吧？这是因为这些书体量巨大且价格昂贵得令人望而却步，但它们读起来也确实非常困难。它们布满了华丽的18世纪字母形态，带着卷曲的尾巴和花饰，这让指尖感到困惑。直到多年以后，接近阿维一生的尽头，即1821年，
that a very different blind reading system begins to develop. One that uses dots instead of lines. It starts when a captain from Napoleon's army visits the school to share a system that he developed for French soldiers. The captain describes how the system allowed his men to silently communicate with each other on battlefields at night. This is a clip from a very lively educational movie about this history. Then I came up with a brilliant idea of making signs that my men could read in the dark merely by touch.
一种截然不同的盲人阅读系统开始发展起来。一个用圆点代替线条的系统。这一切始于拿破仑军队的一位上尉访问该校，分享他为法国士兵开发的一套系统。这位上尉描述了这套系统如何让他的士兵在夜间战场上进行无声的交流。这是一段关于这段历史的非常生动的教育短片的剪辑。然后我想出了一个绝妙的主意，制作出我的士兵在黑暗中仅凭触觉就能阅读的符号。
I called it nocturnal writing. The director of the school at the time led a group of students' experiments with the embossed pages that the captain had left behind, and in that group was a 12-year-old blind kid named Louis Braille. Over the next few years, he began to adapt that military code for blind people as an alternative to raised print. Louis, you've been working on that for days. Your mother's worried. Can't you take a break? No, I am so close. of two raised print. Louis Braille simplified the military code and maximized its efficiency.
我称之为夜间书写。当时学校的校长带领一群学生用这位上尉留下的浮雕页做实验，其中有一个12岁的盲童，名叫路易·布莱叶（Louis Braille）。在接下来的几年里，他开始将这种军事密码改编成盲人使用的系统，作为凸版印刷的替代品。路易，你已经连续几天在弄那个了。你母亲很担心。你就不能休息一下吗？不，我就快成功了。凸印文字的替代品。路易·布莱叶简化了军事密码，并将其效率最大化。
He substituted the 12-dot system developed by the captain into a six dot system which allowed blind people to read faster by recognizing a letter with the touch of a single finger. And while this code was inscrutable to sighted people, it was the system that blind people needed, designed by a blind person who understood intimately the needs of those reading by touch. Another advocate for the blind would say of Braille, it bears the stamp of genius, like the Roman alphabet itself. But despite its effectiveness,
他把上尉开发的12点系统替换成了6点系统，这让盲人只需用单根手指触摸就能识别一个字母，从而能够更快地阅读。虽然这个密码对视力健全的人来说是不可理解的，但它正是盲人所需要的系统，由一个深刻理解触觉阅读者需求的盲人所设计。另一位盲人权益倡导者对布莱叶盲文这样评价：它带有天才的印记，就像罗马字母本身一样。但尽管它很有效，
Braille didn't catch on right away. It wouldn't become the dominant system in France for another 30 years. And it'd be nearly a century before it became standard for blind readers in the US, because it was effectively suppressed by a well-intentioned, world-famous visionary of blind education.
布莱叶盲文并没有立即流行起来。在法国，它花 了足足30年才成为主流系统。而要花近一个世纪的时间，它才成为美国盲人读者的标准，因为它实际上被一位出于好意、世界闻名的盲人教育远见者压制了。
Around the same time that Braille was quietly developing his new reading system, an American named Samuel Gridley Howe came to visit the Royal Institute in France. He was doing research in anticipation of opening the first school for the blind in the US. And I wish I could tell you that, well in France, how discovered the wonders of Braille, He was doing research and anticipation of opening the first school for the blind in the US. And I wish I could tell you that while in France, how discovered the wonders of Braille, but that's not how it went down.
大约在布莱叶悄悄开发他的新阅读系统的同时，一个名叫塞缪尔·格里德利·豪（Samuel Gridley Howe）的美国人来到法国参观皇家研究所。他在为筹备在美国建立第一所盲人学校做研究。我多么希望我能告诉你，在法国，豪发现了布莱叶盲文的奇妙之处，他在为筹备在美国建立第一所盲人学校做研究。我多么希望我能告诉你，在法国，豪发现了布莱叶盲文的奇妙之处，但事实并非如此。
Instead, he saw the raised letter books and he was intrigued. But in true American fashion, he found all their fancy flourishes, impractical, and typical of European excess. So he decided to make his own system that improved on the Europeans' work. And he came back and he modified it a bit. That's Kim Charlson, the director of the library at the Perkins School, which how established in Massachusetts in 1829. Because they were using a more gothic style font that he felt was a little too ornamental and more difficult to read by touch.
相反，他看到了凸版印刷的书籍，并对此很感兴趣。但出于真正的美国作风，他发现所有那些花哨的花体字都不切实际，是欧洲浮夸作风的典型代表。因此，他决定建立自己的系统，来改进欧洲人的工作。他回来后对其进行了一些修改。说话的是金·查尔森（Kim Charlson），他是帕金斯学校图书馆的馆长，该校由豪于1829年在马萨诸塞州建立。因为他们使用的是一种更具哥特风格的字体，他觉得这种字体装饰性太强，通过触觉阅读起来更困难。
So if one of our wee's French books looked sort of like an ancient tomb in a horror movie, whose letters rise up in fleshy pretubrances, then House System is similar, but it looks more runic, Tolkien-y, elvish. House sharpened his letters' curves into points to make them more distinct under the fingertips. The letter O, for example, is shaped like a diamond. How calls his new system Boston Line Type? Boston Line Type is really the beginning of literacy as we know it as a movement for people who are blind in the United States. And like the older French system, Boston Line Type was designed to be read both by blind and sighted people.
所以，如果说奥韦的一本法国书看起来有点像恐怖电影里的古代陵墓，其字母隆起成肉质的突起，那么豪的系统也很相似，但它看起来更像如尼文、托尔金式的精灵文。豪把字母的曲线磨尖成尖角，以便它们在指尖下更加清晰。例如，字母 O 的形状就像一颗钻石。豪将他的新系统命名为波斯顿线体（Boston Line Type）。波斯顿线体确实是美国盲人运动中我们所熟知的识字教育的开端。和较早的法国系统一样，波斯顿线体旨在让盲人和视力健全的人共同阅读。
If you're able to see and look at one of these books, the letters are totally easily legible. Boston Line Type allows blind people and sighted people to sit down together and to read. There's no barrier between them. And this idea was really important to how. He didn't want blind people to use a system, like Braille, that was separate from what sighted people used. He thought it would isolate blind people and prevent them from integrating into the wider world. Long before the concept of universal design had been articulated, it was informing how it was thinking about how to design for people with disabilities.
如果你能看东西并查看其中一本书，这些字母完全是很容易辨认的。波斯顿线体允许盲人和视力健全的人坐在一起阅读。他们之间没有障碍。这个理念对豪来说非常重要。他不希望盲人使用像盲文那样与视力健全者所用系统相隔离的系统。他认为这会孤立盲人，并阻碍他们融入更广阔的世界。早在通用设计的概念被明确提出之前，它就已经在指导豪如何为残疾人进行设计了。
And also, you can imagine the argument, well, we want our kids that are blind and vision impaired to use the same system that our side of kids use, right? That sounds good, right? But it turns out that raise letters are just not as good as a braille. Why not? So it's harder.
此外，你可以想象那种争论，好吧，我们希望我们失明和视力受损的孩子使用我们健全的孩子使用的同一套系统，对吧？听起来不错，对吧？但事实证明，凸起字母就是不如盲文好用。为什么不好用？所以它更难。
It just is harder. That's not intuitive to people who are cited, but those letter forms are just not unique enough from each other. Sighted people look at brailing, oh, that all looks the same. But under the finger, those raised dots underneath your finger are just more tangible. They just are. And not only that, you can write in braille. Unlike raised print, it doesn't require a big heavy metal printing press.
它就是更难。对于视力健全的人来说，这并不直观，但那些字母形态彼此之间不够独特。视力健全的人看着盲文会说，哦，这看起来都一样。但在手指下面，你手指底下的那些凸起圆点更加切实可感。它们就是这样。不仅如此，你还可以用盲文书写。与凸版印刷不同，它不需要大型沉重的金属印刷机。
All you need is a small, simple tool called a slate and stylus that fits in your pocket. By the 1860s, some schools of the blind in the US had begun experimenting with Braille. And while many faculty members still resisted it as an arbitrary, impenetrable system, the blind students who were exposed to Braille argued passionately for its superiority to raised letters. At the Missouri School for the Blind, students passed each other notes, and reportedly even love letters in Braille, since they knew their teachers wouldn't be able to read them if they got caught.
你需要的只是一个可以放进口袋里的小巧简单的工具，叫做写字板和笔。到了19世纪60年代，美国的一些盲人学校开始尝试盲文。虽然许多教职员工仍然将其视为一种随意的、难以理解的系统而加以抵制，但接触到盲文的盲人学生则热情地争辩说，盲文比凸体字优越得多。在密苏里盲人学校，学生们互相传递字条，据报道甚至还用盲文写情书，因为他们知道如果被抓到，老师是读不懂的。
But how had invested a massive amount of time and resources into developing, distributing, and promoting Boston Line Type? And he'd become a hugely influential celebrity in the field of blind education. He was a master fundraiser, and key to that fundraising apparatus was the spectacle of a deafblind girl named Laura Bridgman, who how taught to read using Boston Line Type. Bridgman was the first deafblind person in history to get an education, more than a full generation before Helen Keller did. This achievement made Laura Bridgman and Howe, international stars, which Howe leveraged
但豪在开发、分发和推广波斯顿线体方面投入了大量的时间和资源。他在盲人教育领域成了一个极具影响力的名人。他是一位出色的筹款大师，而这一筹款机制的关键是一个名叫劳拉·布里奇曼（Laura Bridgman）的盲聋女孩，豪曾教她使用波斯顿线体阅读。布里奇曼是历史上第一个接受教育的盲聋人，比海伦·凯勒早了整整一代人。这一成就使劳拉·布里奇曼和豪成为了国际巨星，豪利用这一点，
to make Boston Line Type one of the dominant print mediums for the blind across the US. Like Howe, many of the directors and faculty at schools for the blind were sighted, and many of them believed that they knew which system was best. Well, it's easy for me reading a print letter, so it's going to be easy for them with their fingers, you know. And I think it's a failure of imagination or a failure of empathy or a failure of experience. Catherine Cudlick directs the Paul K. Longmore Institute on Disability at San Francisco State, where she's also a history professor.
使波斯顿线体成为全美盲人主流的印刷媒介之一。像豪一样，盲人学校的许多董事和教职员工都是视力健全的人，他们中的许多人相信他们知道哪种系统最好。好吧，我阅读印刷字母很容易，所以他们用手指读也会很容易，你知道的。我认为这是想象力的失败，或者是同理心的失败，或者是经验的失败。凯瑟琳·库德利克（Catherine Cudlick）在旧金山州立大学主持保罗·K·朗莫尔残疾人研究所（Paul K. Longmore Institute on Disability），她同时也是那里的历史学教授。
And she doesn't even really buy house argument that Boston Line Type was universal. You might have thought of this universal, but it's universal in that way that the colonizer thinks things are universal. It's like, you know, these poor native peoples need educating and we'll try to bring them up to my level and make them like me. They didn't get the blind people to be the experts. There's a crucial part is, I mean that's like a disability rights refrain is nothing. Nothing about us without us, yeah. In fact, the new way that people are starting to say it is
她甚至并不真正买账豪关于波斯顿线体是普适的这一论点。你可能认为这是普适的，但它的普适方式正是殖民者认为事物是普适的那种方式。就像，你知道的，这些可怜的土著人民需要教育，我们要试着把他们拉到我的水平，让他们变得像我一样。他们没有让盲人成为专家。这是一个至关重要的部分，我的意思是，这就像是一个残疾人权利的副歌：“没有我们的参与，就不要做任何关于我们的决定”（Nothing about us without us），是的。事实上，现在人们开始说的新说法是，
nothing without us. Period. I think how probably made a good faith effort to create a universal system, one that predicted universal design, one that he hoped would erase the line, dividing the blind from the sighted. But paradoxically, in committing so strongly to the universal page of Boston Line Type, how helped delay the adoption of a much better system by close to 100 years in the US? A system where the blind person, Louis Braille, was the expert. By the early 20th century, how had died.
没有我们就什么都没有。句号。我认为豪可能出于善意创建了一个普适系统，一个预示了通用设计的系统，一个他希望能够消除盲人与视力健全者之间界限的系统。但矛盾的是，由于对波斯顿线体的普适版面过于执着，豪在无形中在美国推迟了近100年才采用一个好得多的系统。那是一个以盲人路易·布莱叶为专家的系统。到20世纪初，豪已经去世。
There were growing numbers of organizations dedicated to serving the blind, and more and more of them were being led by blind people. In 1921, leaders from the most influential of these groups gathered in rural Iowa to form the American Foundation for the Blind. The AFB quickly became the most powerful blindness organization in the US, and one of their first priorities was to make Braille, the dominant system. But Americans being Americans, the same thing happened that it happened with raised letters. We decided that we could design things better than those pretentious Europeans could. So a whole cottage industry arose with all sorts of
致力于服务盲人的组织越来越多，其中越来越多的组织开始由盲人领导。1921年，这些组织中最具影响力的领导人们聚集在艾奥瓦州的一个乡村，成立了美国盲人基金会（American Foundation for the Blind）。AFB迅速成为美国最强大的盲人组织，他们的首要任务之一就是让盲文成为主流系统。但美国人毕竟是美国人，同样的事情还是发生了，就像对待凸字印刷时一样。我们决定，我们可以比那些自命不凡的欧洲人设计出更好的东西。因此，一个庞大的家庭手工业涌现出来了，伴随着各种各样，
competing systems, Braille knockoffs. So now we're heading into what we call the war of the dots. Have you heard of that? We could spend an entire episode on the war of the dots with Mike Hudson as our trusting narrator, but in a nutshell, before Braille truly won out in the US, there was another 50 years of competing tactile systems. This period drove many blind readers bananas because every library for the blind was filled with books printed in these multiple competing systems. New York Point, Moon Type, American Modified Braille. There are others, by the way. We're not going to go into them. But at one point, the head of the Perkins school says, you know, if anybody invents another code for the blind, we want to shoot them on the spot.
相互竞争的系统，盲文的仿制品。所以现在我们要进入我们所说的“圆点战争”。你听说过这个吗？我们可以花一整集的时间来聊聊“圆点战争”，由迈克·哈德森担任我们信赖的讲述者，但简而言之，在盲文真正在美国胜出之前，还有另外50年的触觉系统竞争期。这段时期让许多盲人读者快要发疯了，因为每个盲人图书馆都挤满了用这些相互竞争的多种系统印刷的书籍。纽约点字法（New York Point）、月亮体（Moon Type）、美国改良盲文（American Modified Braille）。顺便说一句，还有其他的。我们就不细讲了。但有一次，帕金斯学校的负责人说，你知道的，如果有人再为盲人发明一种密码，我们当场就想枪毙他。
The decisive battle in the war of the dots finally came in 1909. Cities like New York were rapidly growing, and for the first time, they had enough blind children to start building day schools for the first time, they had enough blind children to start building day schools for the blind. And so they have a nice big, two day knock down drag out meeting of the New York Board of Education to decide which code they're going to use in the New York City Schools. So they bring in all the heavy hitters. Okay.
点字战争中的决定性战役最终发生在1909年。像纽约这样的城市正在快速发展，他们第一次拥有了足够的盲童来开始建立日间盲校。
I mean, everybody's anybody in line is testifies before this body. And at the end, they take a big vote, and they vote for Braille, okay? It's the beginning of the end for the competing codes. By 1917, the rest of the country follows New York's lead, and the newly standardized English Braille becomes the main way blind children are taught to read in the US.
因此，纽约市教育局举行了一次规模宏大、为期两天的激烈会议，以决定在纽约市学校里使用哪种代码。所以他们把所有重量级人物都请来了。好吧。
And with their increasing self-determination and literacy, blind people are more able to integrate into society than ever before. Blind children are starting to be mainstreamed into public schools, and for the first time, some blind people are getting office jobs using tech-like Braille typewriters so they can work alongside sighted people, as equals. It's what how had hoped Boston line-type would help them do. But for all braille's advantages over raised print, it didn't work for all blind people, like the thousands of soldiers who were coming back from war with eye injuries, who hadn't learned braille as kids. As you probably noticed, listening to me struggle to read that stupid sentence about my niece doing puzzles.
我的意思是，所有在盲人领域有点名望的人都在这个机构面前作证。最后，他们进行了大投票，他们投票选择了盲文，好吧。这是这些竞争代码走向终结的开始。到1917年，全国其他地区效仿了纽约的做法，新标准化的英文盲文成为美国盲人儿童学习阅读的主要方式。
Puzzles? My niece can write a unicycle or do puzzles. Learning Braille as an adult is really hard. My niece can write a unicycle or do puzzles. But as sound recording became easier and more affordable, those people who'd become blind later in life had new options. Options that would transform our ideas of what a book can be. Translating ink print books into sound might seem more straightforward than building a
随着盲人自决权和识字能力的提高，他们比以往任何时候都更能融入社会。盲童开始被主流公立学校接纳，盲人第一次能够使用盲文打字机等技术做办公室工作，这样他们就能和视力健全的人一起工作，作为平等的人。这就是豪曾希望波斯顿线体能够帮助他们做到的事情。但尽管盲文比凸体字有种种优势，它并不适合所有盲人，比如成千上万从战场归来、眼睛受伤且在童年时没有学过盲文的士兵。正如你可能注意到的，听我艰难地阅读那个关于我侄女做拼图的愚蠢句子。
tactile reading system, after all books were born out of a few thousand years of people telling each other stories, and we all learned to read by having books read to us. But early efforts to make recordings of books for blind readers brought with them a new set of design challenges. The American Foundation for the Blind partnered with the Carnegie Corporation to publish experimental books on phonographic records. They called them talking books. They hired narrators and pressed the recordings onto long-playing records, 25 minutes aside. These books were circulated by blind people about a decade before LPs became available to the wider public. The first
拼图？我侄女可以骑独轮车或者做拼图。成年后学习盲文真的很难。我侄女可以骑独轮车或者做拼图。但随着录音变得更加容易和实惠，那些在晚年失明的人有了新的选择。这些选择将改变我们对“书”是什么的观念。将油墨印刷书籍翻译成声音，似乎比建立一个，
audiobooks and the first LPs were made for blind readers. But these talking books raised big questions. What should a book sound like? How do you translate the elements of a codex, which is a fancy word for the thing that we usually call a book with paper pages, ink, and binding? How do you translate one of those things into sound? The definition of the book basically imploded
触觉阅读系统要来得更直接，毕竟书籍诞生于几千年来人们互相讲故事的历史，而且我们大家都是通过听别人读书来学会阅读的。但是，早期为盲人读者制作书籍录音的努力，带来了一组新的设计挑战。美国盲人基金会与卡耐基公司合作，在留声机唱片上出版实验性书籍。他们称之为“有声书”（talking books）。他们雇用了旁白朗读员，并将录音压制到长效唱片上，每面播放25分钟。这些书籍在LP唱片向广大公众普及大约十年前就在盲人中流传了。最早的，
right after these talking books started to be developed because all sorts of producers started to come up with new ideas for things that they would call talking books that certainly had nothing to do with the Codex form. That's Mara Mills. She's a professor at NYU who works at the intersection of media and disability studies. And I promise she's the last academic I'm going to introduce you to. Let's treat our chat for a minute and let me do it.
有声书和最早的LP唱片都是为盲人读者制作的。但这些有声书引发了重大的问题。一本书听起来应该是什么样的？你如何将法典（codex，这是一个花哨的词，用来指代我们通常称为带有纸质页面、油墨和装订的书的东西）的元素转化？你如何将其中一样东西转化为声音？“书”的定义基本上瓦解了，
Bringing the treat feedback like songs. The Cornell Ornithology Lab, for instance, decided that they wanted to take some of their bird song recordings and make a talking book for blind people out of them. They're songs that are among the finest of American birds and they're rival and perhaps surpass. When Snow White came out as an early animated talking movie, the AFB decided they wanted to make a talking book version of a talking movie. Walt Disney's Snow White and the Seven Worts recorded solely for the use of the blind. There was no book, origin.
在这些有声书开始开发后不久，因为各种制作人开始为他们称之为“有声书”的东西想出新的点子，这些东西肯定与法典形式毫无关系。说话的是玛拉·米尔斯（Mara Mills）。她是纽约大学的一位教授，从事媒介与残疾研究的交叉领域工作。我向你保证，她是我要向你介绍的最后一个学术界人士。让我们暂时转换一下话题，由我来做这件事。
They called it a book, and they circulated it as a talking book, but it was a audio description of the images in an animated film with some of the sound files and dialogue from that film. When he was right behind Snow White, he drew his big knife, then Snow White noticed a shadow on the ground. Whitey drew his big night, then Snow White noticed a shadow on the ground. Very quickly, all sorts of things began to be called books that had very marginal relationship to the book form. And as talking books became more elaborate and theatrical, more filled with sound effects and music, some blind people grew frustrated. More and more blind readers wound up breaking their record players trying to speed up the voices of the narrators. and the way the music was played by the band. The music was played by the band. The music was played by the band. The music was played by the band. The music was played by the band. The music was played by the band.
将树木的反馈像歌曲一样带入。例如，康奈尔鸟类学实验室决定，他们要挑出一些鸟鸣录音，并为盲人制作一本有声书。它们是美国鸟类中最动听的歌声，它们可以媲美甚至超越。当《白雪公主》作为早期动画有声电影上映时，AFB决定他们想制作有声电影的有声书版本。华特迪士尼的《白雪公主和七个小矮人》仅供盲人使用。没有原著书籍。
The music was played by the band. The music was played by the band. The music was played by the band. The music was played by the band. The music was played by the band. The music was played by the band. The music was played by the band. The music was played by the band. flourishes of music and sound effects got in the way of blind people's desire for speed. And so talking books began to sound different. The Holy Bible, the King James Version, read by Alexander Scorpio.
他们称它为一本书，并作为有声书发行，但它是对动画电影中画面的音频描述，并配有该电影的一些音效和对白。当他正站在白雪公主身后时，他拔出了大刀，接着白雪公主注意到地上有一个影子。白伊拔出大夜，然后白雪公主注意到地上有一个影子。很快，各种各样的事物都被称为书籍，而它们与图书形式的关联却微乎其微。随着有声书变得越来越精致、戏剧化，充满了音效和音乐，一些盲人感到沮丧。越来越多的盲人读者最终为了加快旁白朗读者的语速而弄坏了他们的唱片机。乐队演奏音乐的方式。乐队演奏音乐的方式。乐队演奏音乐的方式。乐队演奏音乐的方式。乐队演奏音乐的方式。乐队演奏音乐的方式。
No nonsense narrators, like Alexander Scorpio, became more popular in the 1940s and 50s. And their voices became almost like fonts, standardized, legible, and most importantly, conveying information without getting in the way, more like the narrators of contemporary audiobooks. In the beginning God created the heaven and the earth, and the earth was without form and void, and darkness was upon the face of the deep, and the spirit of God moved upon the face of the waters. And God said, let there be light, and there was light." The book historian Matthew Rubery told me that if you bring up the name Alexander Scorby
乐队演奏音乐的方式。乐队演奏音乐的方式。乐队演奏音乐方式。乐队演奏音乐的方式。乐队演奏音乐的方式。乐队演奏音乐方式。乐队演奏音乐的方式。音乐和音效的花哨装饰阻碍了盲人对速度的追求。因此，有声书的声音开始变得不同。《圣经》詹姆斯国王钦定版，由亚历山大·斯科比朗读。
with a blind person of a certain age, their eyes will fill with tears because of the associations they have with his voice. They grew up listening to him, reading him. So perhaps this is my consolation as I become a blind reader. I can just trade a visual typeface for a verbal one. Let there be a firmament in the midst of the waters and let it divide the waters from the waters. In some ways, my fears about losing my visual relationship to books resembles the anxieties that sighted people have about the demise of print in the digital age. As more and more people read on screens, there's an old guard who bemoans these new forms
在20世纪40和50年代，像亚历山大·斯科比这样脚踏实地的旁白变得更受欢迎。他们的声音几乎就像字体一样，标准化、易读，最重要的是，在不碍事的情况下传递信息，更像是当代有声书的旁白。起初上帝创造天地。地是空虚混沌，渊面黑暗；上帝的灵运行在水面上。上帝说：“要有光”，就有了光。”图书历史学家马修·鲁伯里（Matthew Rubery）告诉我，如果你向某个年龄段的盲人提起亚历山大·斯科比的名字，
of reading as inferior. These critics believe that the trusty old technology of the book will always be the superior vehicle for ideas. You can hear this conservatism and condescension, not only in those people who malign the e-book, but also in the voices of people who say that you haven't really read a book if you listen to it. They contend that real reading only happens with the eyes. But the history of blindness and reading shows that the way we read has always been in flux. The media scholars and book historians I talked to all told me the same thing. Reading doesn't happen in the eyes or the ears or the fingers, it happens in the brain. And this is a nice thing to hear if you're going blind.
他们的眼睛会因为对他的声音的联想而充满泪水。他们是听着他的朗读、听着他的声音长大的。所以，这也许是我成为一名盲人读者的安慰。我可以把视觉字体换成口头字体。愿诸水之间有空气，将水分为水。在某些情况下，我对失去与书籍的视觉关系的恐惧，类似于视力健全的人对数字时代印刷品消亡的焦虑。随着越来越多的人在屏幕上阅读，有一群保守派哀叹这些新形式，
It makes me feel like, forget my stupid eyes, I'll still have my brain, and that's where all the good stuff happens anyway. But this idea doesn't really soften or mask the fact that blindness is inescapably a loss. No amount of historical research or conceptual reframing can hide the simple equation at work here. I love books, ink print books, with marginalia and typefaces and dingbats, and going blind will take that away from me. But I can't let that be my only conclusion that blindness equals loss full stop.
的阅读是劣质的。这些批评者认为，值得信赖的老旧图书技术永远是承载思想的优越载体。你不仅能在那些诋毁电子书的人身上听到这种保守和居高临下的态度，还能在那些说如果你靠听来读一本书就不是真正读过书的人的声音中听到。他们坚称真正的阅读只能通过眼睛来完成。但失明与阅读的历史表明，我们的阅读方式一直在不断变化。我交谈过的媒体学者和图书历史学家都告诉我同样的事情。阅读不是发生在眼睛、耳朵或手指中，它发生在头脑中。如果你正在失明，听到这个会感觉很好。
Mara Mills told me about someone she met, whose story could offer me an example of a different way to approach my life as a blind reader. His name is Harvey Lauer. He's a blind guy who worked at the VA, testing all kinds of technology for the visually impaired. When you turn on the machine, you hear all the sounds in the earphone. This is Harvey using an optophone, a kind of scanner that would look at text and turn it into a series of tones representing the shapes of the letters. It's another spin on universal design for blind readers. With an optophone, you wouldn't need to create special books for the blind at all, with training a blind person could read an ink print book using one of these devices. The Octophone was first developed in 1912, but this recording is from 1971. Reading sounds like this. First off, find the line.
玛拉·米尔斯（Mara Mills）跟我讲过她遇到过的一个人，他的故事为我提供了一个例证，让我看到了作为一名盲人读者，如何以一种不同的方式来面对生活。他叫哈维·劳尔（Harvey Lauer）。他是个盲人，曾在退伍军人事务部工作，为视障人士测试各种各样的技术。当你打开机器时，你会在耳机里听到所有的声音。这是哈维在使用光电读谱器（optophone），这是一种扫描仪，可以读取文字并将其转化为一系列代表字母形状的音调。这是为盲人读者实现通用设计的另一种尝试。有了光电读谱器，你根本不需要为盲人制作专门的书籍，经过训练，盲人可以使用这些设备之一来阅读油印书籍。八音度读谱器（Octophone）于1912年首次开发，但这段录音来自1971年。阅读的声音听起来就像这样。首先，找到这行字。
And then we'll read. Incredibly, some blind people actually learned how to read this way. After a lot of practice, they could hear these sounds and decode the words they represented. Reading entire novels, using what came to be called musical print. It's at the necessary functions of the... Using the devices he tested for the VA, Harvey could read by vibration through musical print, plus Braille and super sped up talking books. He reads using more of his body, more of his senses than perhaps anyone else on the planet.
然后我们开始阅读。令人难以置信的是，一些盲人竟然学会了用这种方式阅读。经过大量的练习，他们可以听到这些声音并解码它们所代表的单词。阅读整部小说，用的是后来被称为“音乐字体”的技术。这是...的必要功能。利用他在退伍军人事务部测试的设备，哈维可以通过音乐字体的振动来进行阅读，此外还有盲文和超速有声书。他阅读时调动的身体部位、调动的感官，可能比地球上的任何人都要多。
His colleagues called him a cyborg. He walked around with these devices dangling around his neck wherever he went, emitting vibrations and synthetic musical tones. I had to turn up the threshold after empirical... Mara told me that this sometimes led to funny incidents of confusion. Like the time Harvey walked into a 7-11 and heard all these electronic tones coming out of the various machines in the store. He tried decoding them because it seemed to him like they should be alphabetic. And then he realized, nope, there's just electronic tones. It's just the cash register.
他的同事们管他叫“赛博格”（半机械人）。无论他走到哪里，这些设备都挂在他的脖子上晃荡，发出振动和合成的音乐音调。我不得不把阈值调高，在经验...玛拉告诉我，这有时会导致一些有趣的误会。比如有一次，哈维走进一家7-11便利店，听到店里各种机器发出各种电子音。他试着去解码它们，因为在他看来这些声音应该是字母。然后他意识到，不对，那只是电子音。那只是收银机。
Harvey's mistake in the 7-11 suggests to me a way that my future as a blind reader might actually signal something other than a total loss. Blindness could add something to my life, even as it takes something else away. Learning to read in new ways through new senses could increase my appreciation for the world around me. Harvey told Mara that he finds the electronic tones and chords of the optophone beautiful. He said they remind him of Debussy's music, which gives me hope that whichever way I end up reading, through sped-ups, synthetic speech, or braille,
哈维在7-11的失误向我暗示了一种可能，即我作为一名盲人读者的未来，可能并不完全意味着彻底的失去。失明或许会给我的生活增添一些东西，尽管它也带走了别的东西。通过新的感官以新的方式学习阅读，可能会增加我对周围世界的欣赏。哈维告诉玛拉，他觉得光电读谱器的电子音和和弦很美。他说这让他想起德彪西的音乐，这让我感到希望：无论我最终选择哪种阅读方式——是通过加速的合成语音、盲文，
or maybe some high-tech post-optophonic cyborg system that's yet to be invented, that I'll find the beauty in that kind of reading, too. I really should use the other earphones and plug in the other speaker. You have a pathesis or replace it with a more adequate one. Failure to find. Failure to find support for high pathesis. There's not necessarily reflect on the Wally.
还是某种尚未被发明的、高科技的后光电读谱器赛博格系统，我也能在那种阅读中发现美。我真的应该用另一只耳机，插上另一个扬声器。你有一个假设（pathesis）或者用一个更合适的来代替它。未能找到。未能找到支持高假设（high pathesis）的证据。这不一定反映在华莱士（Wally）身上。
Two. Coming up, updates from Andrew Leeland and more about his new book, That's After the Break. I'm back talking with Andrew Leeland about what's happened in the past few years since the story came out and about his new book. It's called The Country of the Blind and it's out today. So Andrew, I remember you were reporting this story and sometime early in the process, you learned that you might not be going blind as quickly as you once thought and it made you question whether or not you should do the story and We assured you that we thought you were the right person for the story and that you should produce it
二。接下来，将为您带来安德鲁·利兰（Andrew Leeland）的最新动态，以及更多关于他新书的内容，中场休息之后继续。我回来和安德鲁·利兰聊聊，自从这个故事问世以来的几年里发生了什么，以及他的新书。这本书名为《盲人国度》（The Country of the Blind），今天刚刚出版。所以安德鲁，我记得你在报道这个故事时，在过程的早期某个时候，你得知自己可能不会像曾经想象的那样迅速失明，这让你质疑自己是否应该做这个报道，我们向你保证，我们认为你是这个故事的最佳人选，你应该把它制作出来。
and it was lovely and years later. I'm reading this book and That anxiety of whether or not you are blind enough for the right kind of blind It kind of pervades the right kind of blind, it kind of pervades the memoir in fascinating ways. And it's not just you, like other people that you interviewed expressed this. Can you talk a little bit about that and what it says about our societal conception of blindness? Yeah, I mean, I think it's a kind of imposter syndrome that I feel.
而且它非常棒，多年后。我正在读这本书，那种关于你是否“盲得足够彻底”、是否达到了“正确类型的失明”的焦虑，这种焦虑以一种迷人的方式弥漫在整部回忆录中。而且不只是你，你采访的其他一些人也表达了这一点。你能谈谈这一点，以及它说明了我们社会对失明的什么观念吗？是的，我的意思是，我觉得这是一种冒名顶替综合征。
And it really began when I started using the white cane, which like all the blindness tools that I use, I had to kind of proactively adopt before it felt absolutely necessary, because that's how this sort of very slow process works, where certainly there could be a moment where I say, okay, I can no longer see the words on the page, so I need to learn how to use a screen reader, say, or learn Braille. You know, if I waited that long, I would be in deep trouble. Much better to learn that skill in advance. And the cane was that way, too, where I thought,
这种感觉真的始于我开始使用白手杖的时候，就像我使用的所有失明辅助工具一样，我必须在绝对必要之前就主动去采用它，因为这种非常缓慢的过程就是这样运作的，当然，可能会有这样一个时刻，我说，好吧，我再也看不清书页上的字了，所以我需要学习如何使用屏幕阅读器，或者学习盲文。你知道，如果我等那么久，我就会陷入大麻烦。最好提前掌握这项技能。手杖也是如此，当时我想，
okay, I've kicked three dogs at this point. I think it's probably time to adopt the cane. But as soon as that cane comes out in public, you're really forced right up against that perception of blindness as a binary. And people say, you're not really blind. What are you doing with that cane? And that's something that I felt and I kind of could like, distantly sense on people's
好吧，我已经踢了三条狗了。我想现在大概是时候使用手杖了。但只要那根手杖一出现在公共场合，你就会被迫直面那种将失明视为二元对立的认知。人们会说：“你并不是真的盲人。你拿着那根手杖在干什么？”这是我能感受到的一种情绪，我甚至能在人们的...
faces. And then there were a few times where I heard it explicitly. Some guys say, you're not, you can see. And it really highlights that disconnect between the experience of blindness, which more often than not is ambiguous in that way. Where there is some vision, It's only something like 10 or 15% of blind people have no light perception. And whether you have just a little bit of light perception or, you know, like I do, like low vision where there's still a few good degrees of central vision that I can use to see a lot of stuff, all of that complicates blindness in a way. But yeah, the broader world has a lot of trouble understanding that idea.
脸上隐约察觉到这种审视。而且有好几次，我听到人们直接这么说。有些家伙说：“你不是盲人，你能看见。”这真的突显了失明的实际体验与社会认知之间的脱节，大多数情况下，失明的体验并不是那么非黑即白的。也就是还保留着一些视力。只有大约10%或15%的盲人没有任何光感。无论你只有一点点光感，还是像我一样——属于低视力，仍然有几度很好的中心视力可以用来看到很多东西——所有这些都让失明的状况变得复杂。但是，是的，更广泛的世界在理解这个概念时遇到了很大的困难。
Yeah, that number of less than 15% of blind people have no light perception. It surprised me and I don't know, I feel like I know things. Yeah, that's sort of stunning. Yeah, I don't know. I mean, I think about the definition of blindness means a destitution of sight.
对，不到15%的盲人没有任何光感这个数字。这让我很震惊，我不知道，我感觉自己懂得挺多。是的，这简直惊人。是的，我不知道。我的意思是，我想想失明的定义意味着丧失视力。
And you know, that makes a certain amount of blindness means a destitution of sight. And you know, that makes a certain amount of sense that we want to define something in these binary terms. But the reality is that it doesn't work that way. And blindness is a spectrum. And even people who have had their optic nerve completely severed, which is to say, technically in a scientific sense, no light is being perceived by their eyes. They describe a kind of visual tinnitus where there's swirling and flashing and undulating
你知道，这在某种程度上合乎情理，失明意味着丧失视力。而且你知道，我们想要用这种二元对立的术语来定义某种事物，也是有一定道理的。但现实是它并非如此运作的。失明是一个光谱。甚至那些视神经完全被切断的人——也就是说，从科学技术的角度来说，他们的眼睛没有感知到任何光线——他们也会描述一种类似视觉耳鸣的现象，在那里有盘旋、闪烁和起伏的
colors. And so, you know, the idea of vision and the idea of sight extends to all blind people, I'd say. You include this quote from Theodore Adorno at the beginning of the book. It goes that the splinter in your eye is the best magnifying glass. Why did you include that quote? What does that quote mean to you? It's a quote that I wanted to kind of hover
色彩。所以，你知道，视觉的概念和视力的概念适用于所有盲人，我想是这样的。你在书的开头引用了西奥多·阿多诺（Theodore Adorno）的一句话。大意是：“你眼中的刺是最好的放大镜。”你为什么引用这句话？这句话对你意味着什么？这是一句我想让它盘旋
above the whole book because my experience of becoming blind and losing vision is a splinter in the eye. I mean, literally, right? But, you know, not literally a splinter, but literally eye damage, but also, you know, it's a thorn in the side. It's a pain in the ass, but also, I think what Adorno is saying there is that we take these difficult experiences
在整本书上空的引言，因为我失明和失去视力的经历就像是眼里扎了一根刺。我的意思是，字面意思上的，对吧？但是，你知道，并非字面意义上的木刺，而是字面意义上的眼睛损伤，但同时，你知道，这也是一个眼中钉。它是个烦人精，但我也认为阿多诺在那里所说的是，我们经历这些艰难的经历，
and they have this tendency to illuminate the world and to allow us to really pay more attention than we otherwise would. And there's another quote that I like that's sort of related, which is that happiness writes white, which is to say, when things are going good, you're writing white ink on white paper. Like, I don't know, if you ever keep a journal, like, people don't tend to write a lot of journal entries, and things are going well. It's only when you're miserable
它们有一种倾向，能够照亮世界，并让我们比平时更加关注周围的事物。我还有另一句喜欢的、与之相关的名言，那就是：幸福书写白色（happiness writes white），也就是说，当一切顺利时，你就像是用白墨水在白纸上写字。就像，我不知道，如果你记日记的话，人们往往不会在一切顺利时写很多日记。只有当你痛苦的时候，
that you're jotting things down. And so I think I had that experience with this, like, losing vision, becoming blind made me a writer. It really like gave me that feeling of urgency that like, there's something I need to understand about this on a kind of existential level. And not just in like a journaling, like I need to therapeutically process my emotions, but also like, who am I becoming in a philosophical way, in a literal way, but also like, who are my people? And like, what are the ideas that are important to me now? And all that was shifting and it really Clarified it in a way that was did feel like a magnifying glass on my world Yeah
你才会随手记下事情。所以我想我也有过这样的经历，失去视力、逐渐失明让我成了一个作家。它真的给了我那种紧迫感，让我觉得有些事情我需要在一种生存主义的层面上弄明白。不仅是在写日记的层面——比如我需要通过治疗来处理我的情绪，而且还在于：我在哲学上、在字面意义上正在变成一个怎样的人？还有，我的同类是谁？以及，现在对哪些理念对我来说是重要的？所有这些都在发生转变，它确实以一种真正感觉像是给我的世界加上放大镜的方式让一切变得清晰。
This quest for who are my people is a huge and fascinating part of the book I mean it is a a memoir of your own experience But there's so much history and reporting in it and you talk to lots of people for this story Could you talk about some of the more fascinating people that you met along the way and reporting in it. And you talk to lots of people for this story. Could you talk about some of the more fascinating people that you met along the way in reporting the book? Yeah, part of the reporting that I was doing, you know, and it really is like personal reporting, right? Like there are things where I'm being a good disability
对“我的同类是谁”的这种探寻，是这本书中巨大且迷人的一部分。我的意思是，这既是一部关于你个人经历的回忆录，但其中又包含了如此多的历史和报道，你为了这个故事采访了许多人。你能聊聊你在采访过程中遇到的那些更迷人的人吗？以及在报道这本书的过程中。你为了这个故事采访了许多人。你能聊聊你在采访过程中遇到的那些更迷人的人吗？是的，我所做的报道的一部分，你知道，这确实是一种个人报道，对吧？就像有些事情是我在扮演一个合格的残障
journalist and trying to kind of cover the waterfront in that way, but a lot of it is just driven by my own existential feeling of like, well, if I want to be not just a successful blind person, but like a happy, engaged blind person, like let me find some people like that. So a lot of the people I write about in the book are role models in that way, kind of cultivating and collecting blind mentors. And so I found people like this guy Josh Mealy, who recently won a MacArthur Genius grant,
记者，并试图以这种方式覆盖方方面面，但其中很大一部分只是由我自己的存在主义感受所驱动的：好吧，如果我想成为一个不仅成功的盲人，而且是一个快乐的、积极参与生活的盲人，那么让我去找一些这样的人吧。因此，我在书中所写的许多人都是这方面的榜样，这是一种培养和收集盲人导师的过程。所以我找到了像乔施·米利（Josh Mealy）这样的人，他最近赢得了麦克阿瑟天才奖，
and I really think he is a genius, but also just funny and cool and down to earth, and he went blind as a kid, and really didn't like being blind, didn't identify as blind, and then he went to UC Berkeley in the 90s where he was telling me about this place in the basement of Berkeley's Moffitt Library called the Cave, where all the blind students would hang out, and they basically had free 24, 7 access to this suite of offices that was just like a laboratory of assistive technology where they would have these wild devices, like the first screen readers,
我真的觉得他是个天才，但也幽默、酷且脚踏实地。他在童年时失明，曾经非常不喜欢失明，不认同自己是盲人，后来他在90年代去了加州大学伯克利分校，他跟我讲起伯克利莫菲特图书馆（Moffitt Library）地下室一个叫“洞穴”（the Cave）的地方，所有的盲人学生都会在那里闲逛。他们基本上可以24小时免费进入这套办公室，这里就像是一个辅助技术的实验室，里面有各种疯狂的设备，比如第一代屏幕阅读器、
the first video magnifiers, and then these like much weirder devices like the optophone. And he really taught me this idea that blind people are hackers, like not just the hacker blind, there's not just like there's a subgroup of blind hackers, but like really to be blind and to solve the problems that blind this poses to you, you have to be willing to solve problems
第一代视频放大器，还有诸如光电读谱器这样更奇怪的设备。他真正教给我的一个理念是：盲人就是黑客。不仅仅是盲人黑客这个群体——不仅仅是存在一个盲人黑客的小团体，而是说，作为一个盲人，要想解决失明给你带来的问题，你必须愿意以我们认为黑客那种方式去解决问题。你知道，所以像乔施这样的人真的让我觉得失明不仅意味着“这会没事的”，而是“哦，原来如此”——我遇到过的一些最有趣的人都生活在这个世界里。
in the way that we think of hackers doing. And you know, so somebody like Josh really made me feel like blindness was not just like this is gonna be okay, but like, oh well, like some of the most interesting people have met are inhabiting this world. You talk about that you want to cultivate an image of being an active protagonist in your own life. And it sounds like you admire that about Drosh. Could you talk more about that idea and how,
你谈到你想在自己的生活中培养一种作为积极主角的形象。听起来你很欣赏乔施身上的这一点。你能多谈谈这个想法，以及...
you know, popular depiction of blindness are generally, you know, un-todifying it or worse, or just mocking and diminishing because they evolve to non-active protagonists? or worse, or just mocking and diminishing because they evolve to non-active protagonists. Yeah, I mean, to be fair, I think that I recognize in myself a feeling of passivity. I don't think blindness encourages it, but I think that there is a risk where, you know, like in my own home life,
你知道，公众对失明的描绘通常是去人格化的，或者更糟糕的是，仅仅是嘲弄和贬低，因为它们演变为了非积极的主角？或者更糟糕的是，仅仅是嘲弄和贬低，因为它们演变为了非积极的主角？是的，我的意思是，公平地说，我觉得我在自己身上也认出了一种被动感。我不认为失明会鼓励这种心态，但我认为存在这样一种风险，你知道，比如在我自己的家庭生活中，
I notice like, okay, it's gonna be significantly harder for me to find the garbage and the place where the trays are bust in this restaurant. Maybe I'll just let my partner do it. And then I have this sort of internal conflict where I'm like, are you really gonna be that kind of blind person who just lets your wife tidy up for you all the time because you're too blind to take care
我注意到，好吧，在这个餐厅里，我要找到垃圾桶以及收拾托盘的地方要困难得多。也许我还是让我伴侣去做吧。然后我心里就会产生这种冲突，我想：你真的要成为那种盲人吗？因为你觉得自己太盲而无法照顾自己，所以总是让你的妻子帮你收拾屋子？这听起来太糟糕了，所以不行。因此我确实认为，人必须在一定程度上鞭策自己，我自己的经历确实如此。但我觉得你谈到的公众认知，那种需要被照顾的被动盲人形象，不仅是主流形象，而且几乎是大多数人看到的唯一的形象。作为盲人，你对此深有体会。在公共场合使用手杖立刻向我展示的就是这一点，就像一旦
of yourself? That seems horrible, so no. And so I do think there's a certain degree of pushing oneself that has to happen, certainly that I've experienced, but I think what you're talking about in terms of public perception, I think that image of the passive blind person who needs to be taken care of is not only the dominant one, it's almost the only one that most people see, I think. You experience it as a blind person, that's what using a cane in public really showed me immediately was like as soon
那根手杖拿出来，人们就会说：“你站在埃尔姆街（Elm Street）上。”我说：“真的吗？就像我刚从宇宙飞船上掉下来一样，我完全不知道。我在一条我一天走一百遍的路上了。”你知道，但这经常发生。就像，你面前的街道。就像，你知道，我能听到我面前的汽车，我的手杖正在触碰马路牙子，
as that came out, people were like, you're standing on Elm Street. I'm like, really? Like, could I have just been dropped out of a spaceship and like, I have no idea. Like, I'm on this road that I've walked a hundred times a day. You know, but it happens all the time. Like, the streets in front of you. Like, you know, I can hear the cars in front of me, and my cane is touching the curb,
但是至于我本人，这种无助的形象只会让人觉得我根本不知道自己在哪里、在做什么或要去哪里。这不仅是大众的观念，而且，是的，这种观念对盲人的影响之深、持有这种看法的人数之多，怎么强调都不为过。是的，你在书中有一个场景，你提到第一次被触摸
but like what about me, and just this image of helplessness makes you think that I have no idea where I am or what I'm doing or where I'm going, and that is the, not only the popular conception, I think it's, yeah, it can't be overstated how much and how many people think that way about blind people. Yeah, you have this scene in the book where you mentioned like being touched for the first time
当有人在引导你时，当我读到这一段时，我简直浑身发抖——物理意义上的发抖——因为人们觉得他们有权触摸你并引导你。是的，我有一个盲人朋友告诉我，在疫情期间，当那种与他人的亲密接触变成了一种极大的禁忌时，她非常喜欢这种变化，因为这意味着当她在公共场合时，人们
when someone's guiding you and the part of that just made me shudder like physically when I read it that people feel like they have the right to touch you and guide you. Yeah, I have a blind friend who told me that during the pandemic, when that kind of proximity to other people became much more taboo, she loved it because it meant that when she was in public, people just were touching
对她的触碰少之又少。她还告诉我，她某种程度上抓住了“我也是”（Me Too）时代的契机，以及那种变得更加广为人知并被广泛采纳的关于“同意”的语言。你知道，现在如果有人对她做出那样的举动——顺便说一句，这对于许多许多盲人来说是每天都在发生的事情——
her far less. And she also told me that she kind of seized on sort of me too, era, and the language of consent that became much more widely understood and adopted. You know, somebody does that to her now, which by the way, it is a daily occurrence for many, many blind people. You know, she says, I didn't give you consent to touch me. That definitely has a much stronger message than I think if you're just a blind person and say, I know I'm good because people don't believe you. They say, no, no, no, let me just, the elevator's over here. You're like, no, no, no, I'm fine.
你知道，她说：“我没有同意你碰我。”这绝对比你作为一个盲人说“我知道我很好，因为人们不相信你”要传达出更强烈的信息。他们会说：“不，不，不，让我来，电梯在这儿呢。”而你会说：“不，不，不，我很好。”而且你无法说服他们。但如果你说“你没有经我同意就碰我”，这就提醒了他们。哦，对了。这是一个拥有和我一样强烈的个人边界意识的人类。你在书中写到了与社区里一个家伙的一次这种令人不快的相遇，他某种程度上假定了一种亲密感，并开始问你一些关于失明的高度私人的问题。是的。然后你写了这本书。一本关于此的回忆录。是的。你对接下来要发生的事做好准备了吗？呃，比如，会发生什么？听起来很不祥。
And you can't convince them. But if you say, you don't have consent to touch me, it reminds them. Like, oh, right. This is a human being who has the same kind of sense of personal boundaries that I do. You write in the book about this sort of uncomfortable encounter with this guy in the neighborhood who sort of presumes a kind of intimacy and starts asking you like intense questions about blindness. Yeah. And then you wrote this book. That's a memoir about it. Yeah. Are you prepared for what's gonna happen? Um, like, what's gonna happen? You're very ominous sounding.
好吧，我的意思是就人们而言，你知道，他们会假定他们现在对你了解很多，对你产生了一种亲近感，觉得他们可以问你问题。而且还会有像我这样的人来问你问题。我的意思是，这...拥有一个充满了细微差别的故事——其中包含一些痛苦、一些失落、一些胜利，你知道，包含了所有这些东西——谈论这些感觉如何？我觉得那个家伙那么惹恼我，部分原因是我自己还没
Well, but I mean in terms of people, you know, presuming that they now know a lot about you and they feel closeness to you and feel like they can ask you questions. And there's gonna be people like me asking you questions. I mean, is this, how does this feel to have a story with lots of nuance, like it has some pain, has a loss, it has some triumph, you know, it has all this stuff into it, and how does it feel to talk about it? I think that guy bothered me so much in part because I hadn't
问过自己这些问题。比如，他问我：“失明是什么感觉？”这倒没什么，因为人们经常问我这个。虽然还是很烦人，但当他转向我妻子时，我说：“和一个正在失明的男人结婚是什么感觉？”当时我想：“真的吗？现在你开始问她了。”我想这之所以让我如此困扰，是因为莉莉（Lily）和我其实还没有真正谈过这个。虽然我们稍微聊过一点，
asked myself those questions yet. Like, he asked me, you know, what's it like going blind, and that was fine because people asked me that. It was still annoying, but then when he turned to my wife, I was like, what's it like being married to a guy going blind? And I was like, really, like now you're asking her that. And I think it bothered me so much because Lily and I hadn't really talked about it. When we had talked about it a little bit,
但还没聊到能为自己找到答案的程度，更不用说面对这个我们几乎不认识的家伙了。所以我想，在写完这本书后，我现在处于更好的位置来应对这种情况了。我认为我对这意味着什么有了更强的掌控力。而且我想我们对于这对我们的家庭意味着什么有了更好的把握。所以这是一部分。另一部分我认为是，这是无可避免的。我想作为一个盲人，而且我认为对于任何患有
but like not enough to have an answer for ourselves, I think, let alone this guy we barely knew. And so I think I'm in a better position to deal with that now that I wrote the book. And I think I have a much stronger handle on what it means for me. And I think we have a better handle on what it means for our family. So that's one part. The other part I think is that there's no avoiding it. I think as a blind person, and I think this is probably true of anybody with
残障的人来说，对于有显性残障的人来说，这可能都是真的，那就是人们觉得他们有权向你询问此事。这感觉就像是，你身上仿佛挂着一块牌子，上面写着“来问问我身上发生了什么”。就像人们说：“哦，来吧，让我帮你过马路”或者“你是怎么吃饭的”，你知道，那些充满侵入性的问题，他们
the disability, with a visible disability, that is people feel entitled to ask you about it. It's just like, it's almost as though you're wearing a sign that says, like, ask me about what happened to me. And like people saying, you know, oh, here, let me help you cause a street, or like, how do you eat, you know, those kind of invasive questions, they the street, or like how do you eat those kind of invasive questions? They just say, how'd you go blind? You hear this from people who I think wouldn't dare ask a stranger into my questions like that, but somehow disability invites it.
甚至会直接问：“你是怎么瞎的？”你会从那些我认为绝不敢向陌生人提出这种私人问题的人那里听到这种话，但不知为何，残障却招致了这一切。所以我的部分想法是，这是一场注定要输的战斗。无论如何，只要人们看到手杖，就会随时问我这个问题。所以我还不如以这本书的形式给他们一个能想象到的最彻底的回答，而不是把这藏起来。甚至要追溯到13世纪的法国来告诉你这是怎么发生的。
So part of me thinks like, that's a losing battle. Anyway, people are gonna be asking me this any time they see the cane. So I might as well give them the most thorough answer imaginable in the form of this book, rather than just hide it. Go to 13th century France to tell you how this is happening. Yeah. Exactly. So at the end of the book, you come back to HD Wells and you revisit the idea of the country of the blind and you flip it on its head that there that there isn't a country of the blind. You write the blind belong to our world, we belong to theirs, it's the same world.
没错。所以在书的结尾，你回到了H·G·威尔斯（H.G. Wells），你重新审视了《盲人国度》的理念，并将其颠覆，即其实并没有一个盲人国度。你写道：“盲人属于我们的世界，我们属于他们的世界，这是一个世界。”
How did your feelings about the HG Well story change over the course of writing the book? Well, it's hard, because I kind of, I kind of want to have it both ways. You know, I did write that at the end, and I do believe that. You know, and I think it's like this very cheesy sounding but also like incredibly important idea
在写作这本书的过程中，你对H·G·威尔斯的故事的看法发生了怎样的变化？嗯，这很难，因为我有点儿，我有点儿想鱼与熊掌兼得。你知道，我确实在结尾写了那句话，而且我也确实相信这一点。你知道，我觉得这是一个听起来非常老套但同时也极其重要的理念，
that just like, where are people too? You know, and I think it's important to be reminded of, and I think there's a very human tendency to forget about the humanity of people who are different than you. And so like, in some ways that conclusion fell really important, even if it felt really obvious. And it's sort of like, I had to do all of this like really difficult intellectual work to arrive at a conclusion that I probably could have just told you in a cynical way at the beginning, but I think saying the exact same sentence, but really meaning it, you know, with all the force of the research behind it made it feel different.
那就是：我们的同类也在那里，你知道吗？我认为提醒自己这一点很重要，而且人类有一种很强的倾向，会忘记那些与你不同的人的人性。所以从某种程度上说，这个结论感觉非常重要，哪怕它看起来非常显而易见。这就有点像，我不得不做所有这些非常困难的智力工作，才能得出一个我可能在刚开始时就能以愤世嫉俗的方式告诉你结论，但我认为说出完全相同的句子，却真正发自内心地去践行它——带着背后所有研究的力量——让它感觉完全不同。
You know, but I don't want to erase the difference either. And that's sort of the paradox of identity that I wrestle with a lot in my life and in the book, which is to say identity doesn't exist without difference. But then at the same time, you have to be a part of this bigger club of humans, I guess. There's this other idea that I really love. I hear it a lot from different disabled people. And the crux of it is, we need access to your world, right? Like, I want people to write alt text so that I can access images on the internet, but also non-disabled people need access to our world, right? And I think that's another way of putting the same idea
你知道，但我也并不想抹杀差异。这就是我一生中以及在书中一直在纠结的身份认同的悖论，也就是说，没有差异，身份认同就不复存在。但与此同时，我想你必须成为人类这个更大俱乐部的一部分。我真的很喜欢另一个理念。我经常从不同的残障人士那里听到这个说法。其核心是：我们需要进入你们世界的权限，对吧？比如，我希望人们编写替代文本（alt text），以便我可以访问互联网上的图像，但残障人士也需要进入我们世界的权限，对吧？我认为这可以说是对颠覆“盲人国度”这一理念的另一种表述，
of flipping the country of the blind on its head, which is to say like, it's not just about how can you make a bridge to let disabled people understand and be a part of mainstream culture. It's like what can mainstream culture learn from disability culture? What can sighted people learn from blindness? And so I think that's another way that I concluded, I think, this journey was realizing that it's a two way street and there's a lot that sighted people can learn from blindness and vice versa.
也就是说，这不仅仅关乎你如何搭建一座桥梁，让残障人士去理解并融入主流文化；还在于主流文化能从残障文化中学到什么？明眼人能从失明中学到什么？所以我认为这是我在结束这段旅程时得出的另一种认识，那就是这是一个双向街道，明眼人可以从失明中学到很多东西，反之亦然。
Is there something about the book that you want to make sure that people get, like, that is meaningful to you? I guess the big one for me is that if you're sighted and you lose vision, there's inescapable pain in that. You're being disingenuous if you say like, whatevs, like lost my vision, figured out how to be a blind guy, cool. Like, you have to grieve the loss of your sight. But blindness does not have to be a tragedy, and the lived experience of blindness is not one of unremitting tragedy. Other things can make life inescapably unpleasant, and there's certainly aspects of blindness that are unpleasant, but like, in and of itself, there is joy, hilarity, pleasant, but like in and of itself, there is joy, hilarity, weirdness, fun, excitement, and so on in blindness.
关于这本书，有没有什么事情是你希望人们务必能理解的——比如，对你来说意义重大的？我想对我说来最重要的一点是，如果你是一个明眼人却失去了视力，这里面有一种无法逃避的痛苦。如果你说“无所谓啦，反正失去了视力，弄清楚了怎么当个盲人，挺酷的”，那你就是在虚伪地掩饰。你必须为失去视力而感到悲伤。但失明并不一定是一场悲剧，失明的实际生活体验也并非一首永无止境的悲剧。其他事情可能会让生活变得无可避免地令人不快，失明确实也有令人不快的一面，但是，就失明本身而言，其中也充满了
And I think that people don't believe me when I say that. And if there's one thing I want people to take from this book, it's that like blindness is wild and fascinating and not sad as like its primary qualities. This is awesome. Thank you so much. I really enjoyed talking to you. I really enjoyed the book. And I'm just so glad we get to revisit it a few years later. Oh, thank you, Roman. I'm so glad that you read it.
快乐、滑稽、奇异、有趣、兴奋等等元素。而且我认为当我这么说时，人们并不相信我。如果有一件事我希望人们能从这本书中带走，那就是：失明是疯狂的、迷人的，而“悲伤”并非它的核心特质。这太棒了。非常感谢你。我真的很喜欢和你交谈。我也非常喜欢这本书。我真的很高兴几年后我们能重新探讨它。哦，谢谢你，罗曼（Roman）。我很高兴你读了它。
And not only that you enjoyed it, but that you read it. Thank you again. Again, Andrew's book is called The Country of the Blind. It's out today. I highly recommend it. It is fantastic. You should check it out. The original 99% visible episode was produced by Andrew Leeland, edited by Delaney Hall, and mixed by Sheree Fusef.
不仅是你喜欢它，而且你读了它。再次谢谢你。再次说明，安德鲁的书名为《盲人国度》。今天正式出版。我强烈推荐。这本书棒极了。你们应该去看看。最初的99%可见（99% Invisible）节目由安德鲁·莱兰制作，德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）编辑，谢里·福塞夫（Sheree Fusef）混音。
The new content from this week was produced by Kelly Pran. Original music by Swan Rial, who actually used sounds from the optophone in the score, you can see some cool videos of the optophone in action on our website. Many thanks this week to Sorry Outtruler and David Weimer. We found out about the story of Boston Line Type from an exhibition they put together called Touch This Page. The exhibition is also online at touchthispage.com where you can see examples of Boston Line Type and other precursors to Braille.
本周的新内容由凯利·普兰（Kelly Pran）制作。原创音乐由天鹅·里亚尔（Swan Rial）创作，他在配乐中实际使用了光电读谱器的声音，你可以在我们的网站上看到一些光电读谱器运作的精彩视频。本周非常感谢索里·奥特鲁勒（Sorry Outtruler）和大卫·韦默（David Weimer）。我们从他们策划的一个名为“触摸这一页”（Touch This Page）的展览中了解到了波士顿线形字体（Boston Line Type）的故事。该展览也可以在 touchthispage.com 上在线观看，在那里你可以看到波士顿线形字体和其他盲文先驱的实例。
Thanks also to Jen Hale and Jennifer Arnett at the Perkins School, Matthew Rubrie of Queen Mary University of London, whose book about the history of talking books is awesome and Walid Malise of Northeastern's College of Engineering. The rest of the 99PI team includes Chris Barube, Jason Dillion, Emmett Fitzgerald, Martin Gonzalez, Christopher Johnson, Kurt Colestead, Vivian Le, Washington, Madonna, Jaca, Modena, Joe Rosenberg, Interna, Anna Costanero, and me Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are a part of the Stitcher and Sirius XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building, and beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California.
还要感谢珀金斯学校（Perkins School）的詹恩·黑尔（Jen Hale）和詹妮弗·阿内特（Jennifer Arnett），伦敦玛丽女王大学（Queen Mary University of London）的马修·鲁布里（Matthew Rubrie），他关于有声书历史的书非常棒，以及东北大学工程学院的瓦利德·马利斯（Walid Malise）。99PI团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Barube）、杰森·迪利安（Jason Dillion）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martin Gonzalez）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、库尔特·科尔斯泰德（Kurt Colestead）、维维安·勒（Vivian Le）、华盛顿、麦当娜、雅卡、摩德纳、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、实习生安娜·科斯塔内罗（Anna Costanero），以及我——罗曼·马尔斯。99%可见的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。我们是 Stitcher 和 Sirius XM 播客大家庭的一部分，现在总部设在北方六个街区外的潘多拉大厦（Pandora building），位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区。
You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at Nine-Nive-Guy org or on Instagram, Reddit, and TikTok too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99pid. at 99pr.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在 Facebook 上找到本节目并参与关于节目的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我，账号是 Roman Mars，也可以@本节目账号 Nine-Nive-Guy org，或者在 Instagram、Reddit 和 TikTok 上找到我们。你可以在 99pid.org 上找到我喜欢的其他 Stitcher 节目的链接，以及 99PI 的每一期往期节目。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。